yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
finding dory director Andrew Stanton
said they're about 30 to 40 minutes of
scenes were deleted from the movie for
example the tank gang was originally
going to appear in the main part of the
film and there are also some interesting
scenes on the trailers that ended up
being cut so in this video I'm going to
look at some of the fascinating deleted
scenes and rejected concepts that didn't
make it into the final film just before
I start I've got a second copy of this
really beautiful hardback book the art
of finding dory to give away thanks to
my friends at Abrams and Chronicle it's
Patrick gorgeous concept art and
information about how the movie was made
and for a chance to win it's very simple
just subscribe and leave a comment about
the deleted scenes on this video of
course there are spoilers ahead so if
you want to avoid those right here's
where you'll find my non-spoiler review
in the movie when we see the adult dory
for the first time in the movie she's
talking to herself while asleep in her
coral home still asleep she seems like
she's about to sleep swim out of her
home but bumps her head and wakes up
well in the very first trailer for
finding dory we see an alternate version
of this scene where dory also says don't
cry mummy in her sleep and then Nemo
wakes up to find Dory has gone sleep
swimming this scene which was cut from
the final movie was actually one of the
first sequences of the film that went
into production and was part of a much
longer montage of dory sleep swimming
which have been storyboarded in the
storyboarded montage after Marlin pulls
Dory off some coral that she's stuck on
she swims off still asleep as dory swims
she picks up a piece of kelp which
catches and tangles up all the other
fish around her as she swims through the
neighborhood in one version the fish
police are dispatched to try and stop
her with Dory eventually ending up at
the drop-off with all the neighborhood
fish tangled up behind her another
version shows Marlin tying himself a
Nemo to Dory and getting dragged out of
their home when Dory starts sleep
swimming and then the kelp line
connecting them gets cut accidentally by
a swordfish who happens to swim by at
first the beginning of finding Dory was
going to include all of Doras backstory
much like the way Marlins backstory was
told at the start of Finding Nemo
although this technique worked well in
Finding Nemo to make us empathize
marlyn after test screenings of finding
dory at disney the filmmakers found that
they were telling too much of Dory's
past to the start of the film director
Andrew Stanton realized that he needed
to let the audience experience stories
backstories flashbacks little by little
throughout the film and the flashbacks
were actually also more like memory
recalls bhadori which helped us as an
audience experienced her story with her
you might remember Dora's live from
Finding Nemo that I suffer from
short-term memory loss it runs in my
family at least I think it does which
Dory repeats again in this sequel while
the filmmakers initially planned for
both of Dora's parents to also suffer
from short-term memory loss in finding
Dory in fact andrew stanton and
screenwriter Victorious strauss spent
nearly two years developing the story of
Dora's parents with this condition
however they eventually abandoned it as
they found it was too frustrating to
have all of Dory's family talk to each
other and then keep forgetting what
they'd said in the final film
Dora's memory about her parents and
homers triggered after she's knocked out
after getting caught by the undertow
while listening to a group of migrating
rays singing about going home as they
passed by the coral and there were also
another couple of scenes about Dory's
memories that were deleted in the first
Dory and Marlin go to Nemo's parents day
at his school to retell the tale of
Finding Nemo when they leave Dory sees a
seahorse family hugging each other and
she starts to feel lonely and sad in a
second deleted scene Dory spots two blue
fish while playing around the coral and
chases after them after she loses them
she ends up scared and alone until
Marlon and Nemo find him the first
trailer for finding Dory also featured
another alternate scene that was cut
from the movie about how dory remembered
her family that showed dory suddenly
realizing she'd remembered some think
then immediately getting confused and
forgetting what she was talking about
the tank gang make an appearance in
finding Dory 'he's post-credit scene but
they're originally set to appear in a
number of scenes in the main part of the
movie there was going to be a section
where Marlon and Nemo look for Dory in
the shipping lanes after getting
separated from her that scene would have
shown them escaping from a group of
squid by hiding in a shipping container
where they run into the tank gang who
are trapped in a water bottle that's
been thrown overboard from a ship
after Marlon and Nemo helped the tank
gang out of the shipping container Jack
and Peach sneak on to a passing tanker
and then they figure out how to navigate
the marine life Institute on the
Californian coast to find Dory and there
was even an alternate version of this
deleted scene where the tank gang call
on a shoal of flying fish their friends
with who helped them get to California
to find Dory it's such a funny moment
when we meet hank in the movie and he
starts drinking out of that coffee jug
but the animators also had a version of
Hank where it looks like he was a bit of
a hot sauce addict there's some very
cool concept art of Hank hiding himself
in a hot sauce bottle in a similar way
to when he disguised himself as a plant
in his copy jug in the final movie hank
also had what could have been a cool
scene cut around the moment were hank
Andoria and destiny's Paul trying to
figure out how to get to the open ocean
exhibit because they don't know the way
Hank jumps out of the pool and uses a
wet floor caution board to disguise
himself as he retrieves a map on the
ground outside and then he brings it
back for Dory to read the comedy duo
destiny and Bailey were originally going
to have differents and much bigger parts
in the movie
according to Kaitlin Olson who voices
destiny early on in the story's
developments destiny and Bailey were
going to be sisters who were kind of
enemies but who'd come together by the
end of the movie destiny was also going
to be a much more neurotic and
hypochondriac character whose
screenwriter victorious trousers
described as constantly on the verge of
panic and a tremendous joy to write they
were also going to be a lot more jokes
about Bailey's obsession with his head
size and Strasser said she'd love to do
a spin-off movie with the duo well
though we see dory swimming with some
dolphins at the beginning of the movie
at one point in the movie's development
it was actually going to be a group of
hard-of-hearing dolphins of the marine
life Institute the idea was that the
dolphins are being treated for their
hearing injuries there after having
worked with underwater sea mines so
would you like any of those deleted
scenes or concepts to have been in the
final movie or is there anything else
you'd like to have seen in finding dory
for example more of the tank gang do let
me know in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe and leave a comment
for your chance to win this gorgeous
hardback book the art of finding dory
for bonus ways to end the
give away check out the gleam link in
the video description below if you
enjoyed this you might also like my
guide to all the Easter eggs and
references in finding Dory on my video
explaining the amazing deleted scenes
and concepts from Disney Zootopia and
there's links to both those videos which
are in my Pixar and Disney playlist
below thanks for watching and see you
next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers